I recently had a PET scan that showed an additional nodule on the left lobe of my thyroid
where previously I had the right only.
The doctor wanted to remove half my thyroid, well, it was on the right and I declined,
and certainly he will now concertoal want to remove the whole thyroid.
What could I do to shrink these nodules?
Well, again, you want to diagnose what they're from and if they're cancerous,
or if they are from hypothyroidism or Hashimoto's.
So what will cause thyroid nodules?
Well, decrease in iodine will cause thyroid nodules.
It's your iodine levels testing.
Hashimoto's, the number one cause of thyroid nodules, Hashimoto's.
If you had a biopsy, the other nodule biopsy that was cancerous,
that does not mean the other this new nodule is cancer.
So if you're going to get this biopsy, that will tell you the answer to that.
But to remember, the number one cause of thyroid nodules is Hashimoto's.
So don't think that you can't have more than one big going on.
So how do you diagnose Hashimoto's?
You have to do a full thyroid blood flow file.
So full thyroid test is going to include your T3, your T4.
And that's going to be three T3, three T4.
It's going to include your TSH.
It's going to include your TPO antibodies and your thyroid globular antibodies.
And it's going to include reverse T3 would be good to have it out there.
And so just make sure that you look at the biggest picture that you possibly can on your thyroid.
These tests your thyroid antibodies, sorry, these two tests your TPO antibodies
and your thyroid globular antibodies are going to diagnose Hashimoto's.
So if you have TPO and or thyroid globular antibodies that are elevated,
you have Hashimoto's.
If your thyroid is hyperactive and you have either one of these,
then you have what's called Graves' disease.
And that's a much more serious thing that you have to take care of in a different way.
But Hashimoto's is the number one cause of increased nodules.
And don't think even if you have thyroid cancer that will diagnose,
that you can't also have Hashimoto's.